are you guys ready okay let's go let's
go bam
now we can start
guess what from your microbiologist
under all of this it's a lot of rain so
if I'm giving all this I want you to
look good I want you to smell good I
want your smile good I want it all I am
freaking Fired Up For Love Island six
three solid steel and sex appeals not
something you want to walk by Meghan
Margo is a very pretty sight
hi my name is Anna I'm gonna become a
detective if I actually already am that
guy asked me out I will find out his
address I will find out his parents name
I am a little bit of a stalker yeah
let's go
if you're Dominican you better have to
touch growing up they call me La
molasses so slow and smooth that's all
it is I'm gonna always meet your love
language and just show you the best time
mothers hide your sons my name is Cassie
I'm a real estate student I get to work
with my mom who's my boss but also my
best friend I talked to her about
everything unfiltered maybe a little too
much
all right let's do it believe it or not
I have never had a girlfriend I will
write you love letters I am a total
hopeless romantic I am here to find love
like now
I'm this professional girl and then when
I'm not at work I'm absolutely feral
I can't wait to walk in there see my man
shove my tongue down his throat football
has been everything for the majority of
my life a dog on and off the field I let
the dog loose when it comes to chasing
these girls I'm going after what I want
I love love like everywhere I go I'm
looking for love I'm on the dating app
I'm looking for my man like I don't
understand why I haven't found him yet
God
I need you to send me a tall handsome
athletic it hasn't worked yet y'all see
like the 250 pounds wrestler but in the
inside I'm kind of like a big softie I
cannot wait to get into the villa and
find my fairy tale princess
[Music]
I'm looking for my husband I cannot wait
to get started
your Summer of Love is back love Island
USC new season streaming July 18th only
on peacock was that good though yeah
okay good